foreign
[Music]
and welcome back to Rotten Tomatoes is
wrong I am your host Mark Ellis joined
as always by Jacqueline Coley once again
we are in studio and according to you
firsthand we are in airports yes we're
in airports no it is so funny I really
love anyone who's watched us loyalty on
our Ott or on YouTube seeing my
Evolution to actually caring about my
appearance here and that is directly
related to how many of you have started
to come up to me and say oh hey you're
on the TV and I'm like man this podcast
is way more visible than I normally
thought but yeah we're in airports we're
in like three million households like
the video version of this podcast is out
way more than I really I want to get us
to gas station level because you know
sometimes when you pull over and you're
you're filling up gas and you see like
our friend Scott mats I've seen pop up
at a gas station before I'd like to be
in the back of taxis if you're in the
tri-state area that's a big big boost
yeah in a in New York you can could be
in a taxi listening to Scott Mance while
pumping gas like you know what I mean
well the cabbie pulled over yeah and
then you would then drive into the City
and see like a poster of him because he
did like Access Hollywood I do not want
that and you would know every movie
release date by the end of that camera
see I just always like I have it I have
a marks asleep at home and then Mark is
on camera and it's a very similar Mark
it's very it's there really isn't a lot
that changes there may be a little bit
of powder involved if I'm going on stage
which actually is a nice transition
because I happen to as of this recording
be taping my comedy special next
Saturday night December 3rd in Los
Angeles so you all can still get some
tickets are still available I think the
Late Show is just about sold out we have
a seven and a 9 30 it's at the historic
Hayworth Theater which is called Dynasty
typewriter now and you can get tickets
at markellis.live new hour stand if
there's a lot of movie stuff in there it
is there's a whole movie chunk oh wow I
mean you know I love this talk about
what you know can I tell you this is
like somebody who we both know who may
live in my house uh has said that you
were an inspiration to their new
wardrobe Edition they've said that they
want to get a comedian's jacket like
mine because I recently got a members
only jacket a members seeing our next
only jacket yeah that's a comedian's
jacket like y'all all wear the same sort
of like bomber jacket let's bring in our
guest then who actually is a comedian of
no you can also catch him on the big
thing on the Christian harloff and
Friends YouTube channel he is Brett
Sheridan a Joy to the World and we're
talking about hook today uh Steven
Spielberg he's got a new movie coming
out called the Fable men's which
actually is released as of this
recording today on Thanksgiving Happy
Thanksgiving everyone uh Brett do
comedians have a particular jacket that
we all wear
um yes and they all do finger guns in
there
y'all know that every single one of
y'all wear this jacket and in fact I
think it was the jacket you were wearing
in your last special I got one for
Christmas I mean wear a jacket in the
last special but I got one for Christmas
and so I do wear that on stage a fair
amount I didn't know it was the comedian
jacket I only jacket there's not a
specific type but there's a type of I
think jacket that like it's a dark
jacket it comes to your waist you know
what I mean like it's either it's not
quite a Blazer but it's kind of a more
casual version of it I know what you're
saying Blazer bomber yeah well have have
whoever you're talking about have them
have that ready when I come over to your
place next which I hear is actually
going to be in a couple days yes it will
be because it's not really the type of
jacket it's how you pull it off do you
have the right level of desperation and
need to please The Comedians do oh my
God I think these jackets are great by
the way but also tell you this is it the
mistake that a lot of young comedians
make is seeing Robin Williams and his
stand-up which is so fast and quick and
improvisational and he's wearing he goes
Hawaiian shirts we're live at the Met he
went he went uh with a Hawaiian shirt
when he was live at the Roxy in the late
70s when Mork and Mindy was huge he had
that crazy wardrobe and that is the
subject of one of the movies that we're
talking about today hook and you think
Robin Williams is the star of it it's
also got Julia Roberts Dustin Hoffman
Bob Hoskins it's directed by Steven
Spielberg this should be an all-timer in
terms of everything box office Tomato
Meter it's
rotten it is actually very rotten it's
the it's Spielberg currently has three
movies that he directed that are rotten
and hook is the lowest one Hook is 29
the other two I can't even remember them
off the top of my head I'm gonna have to
like pull up research well one is 1941.
that's what it is it's 1941.
1941 is better rated according to the
Tomato Meter anyway and lost world then
Hook and the Lost World Jurassic Park
and this one is as far as hook goes 76
percent of the audience score now he is
still still Steven Spielberg and he
clearly has his fastball because the
fablemans is 95 certified fresh as of
now with an audience score of 91 so the
Fable men's is now out in theaters uh
Nationwide here in the states and hook
is featured in our book Rotten movies we
love which was really the impetus for
this podcast and so Jacqueline it's sort
of like we're back on our most fertile
soil here mining movies that maybe the
public loves but not necessarily really
the critics at least at the time of the
movies release and so we have a couple
editorials at the website we have an
editorial that's ranking every Steven
Spielberg movie best to worst then we
also have the Steven Spielberg Showdown
which I think we're getting into the
final four yes this is the this is uh
online right now you can vote for Steven
Spielberg's it's our bracket challenge
it's like sports bread oh okay I was I
was told there'd be no Sports
well I mean you definitely understand
probably at least the idea of warfare
and so like they're going at it you know
exactly putting it as Dungeons and
Dragons analogy if you want but we've
gotten rid of the pawns we're getting
down here you know this is the final
Rumble uh no and this is what I would
say I believe the ones that are last
it's Jurassic Park uh I I don't think
Schindler's List made it to the end did
it it's it might be his best movie one
best director and it won best picture
but it's not the most uplifting piece
yeah and maybe that's factoring into the
online voting I think that one but I I
definitely know Saving Private Ryan and
Jurassic Park are the two that I believe
are still at the top but I don't quote
me on that one okay well I want to get
into our favorite Spielberg movies as
well and all this good stuff but right
now let's just start with hook and we I
do want to get y'all's take on the
fablements because y'all have both seen
it so we'll get into that later on in
the show after we're done talking about
hooking our many opinions about the 1991
did not according to the Tomato Meter
but first uh Brett Sheridan is hook
fresh or rotten in your eyes is Rotten
Tomatoes wrong about hook Rotten
Tomatoes is wrong about hook
um I don't know why
um I I have a theory that maybe the the
older generation like myself and older
who enjoyed it don't go on the Rotten
Tomatoes and then it gets the younger
people that are taking in now okay
um which is what I viewed in my son's
eyes why he half watched it on his phone
and went like yeah
I'm like see it's it's it's Dad he's
gotta his happy place with his dad is
his being born yeah okay it's kind of
like your son has turned into Robin
Williams's character from the movie
because you because he's on his phone
all the time and now this generation of
kids is on their phone all the time so
maybe that's what that's why we're not
back at Never Never Land it's these damn
phones I mean maybe but also the fact of
like what did Robin Williams phone do
like Robin Williams phone just called
other people to be angry at kid's phone
now can literally bring you you the
world okay but Robin Williams's phone
did flip and that was a big deal because
you could still kind of hang up on
someone angrily and you couldn't do you
can't do it now you just hit a button
I I had I had the more recent flip phone
like the Motorola ones in the in the
mid-2000s but my parents had a car phone
oh wow you were privileged in the mid
90s yeah we felt we felt Big Time wow
driving home from school with the car
phone I don't know that they ever
touched it but it was there it was there
and you were able to use it and I still
remember the number did they have the
Beeper that was this long and my dad had
a good thing but it was a pretty
clandestine beeper he just get paid like
he looks like a drug dealer every time
he got a page that was a doctor uh yeah
yeah so he he'd get a page then he'd
just like leave the restaurant or
wherever and it's like ah dad's going to
do something no
um we did not have car phone energy and
I I had one of those phones like that
but it was like a toy one so I was like
right like I never got the like 80s big
um
the Zack Morris phone the play phone
like that play phone was already dated
by the time I was like whatever but
definitely like the play phone with the
clip that was like a thing you just
needed some sort of thing to flip or to
hang up with with those early cell
phones but if we're talking about the
movie featuring said flip phone one of
the earliest pictures showing a flip
phone by the way yeah uh what does jacly
think about hook Rotten Tomatoes wrong
um I would say that Rotten Tomatoes is
wrong but not that wrong like it's wrong
but not for the reasons you think it's
wrong I call the hook is the
kindergarten qualification of kids
movies this movie is to mature to hit
everything that it needs to hit but it's
too adolescent for parents and sometimes
I think adults to follow along with all
of it yeah The Wonder of it because when
I think of all the parts of this movie
that I love it's all the neverland stuff
and I cannot I literally was like I need
to watch the beginning of this again
because I don't remember any of the like
you know generational trauma stuff like
obviously really yeah it didn't like
click in my head the only thing I really
remembered from that time was the fact
that they very accurately predicted how
Maggie Smith would age but I I know
because Maggie Smith shows up in this
movie we'll talk about movie talk right
now I also think Rotten Tomatoes is
wrong but I don't think they're that
wrong I think I'm with Jacob on this one
where I still think that this is one of
Spielberg's rotten films but I think the
29 is just like it feels like we're
penalizing it's rough yeah I can get it
to 60 because of some of the like Easter
eggs on this movie like because this
it's still very Cinema you're getting
this to 60. you're getting this movie to
Fresh simply because Phil Collins shows
up I'm getting this refresh because
Glenn Close is in drag Glenn Close does
show up as does David Crosby yeah so
like that it's a who's who like that
gets me to 60. you put Glenn Close and
drag and Carrie Fisher does like you
know punch-up lines this is getting to
six yeah Carrie Fisher did do some like
Tinkerbell wine punch up there's a lot
that's more to this movie of like
honestly I just think Steven Spielberg
was like I just want to have fun with my
friends and make a nice little happy
movie and I'll give them that yeah well
there's a lot to this movie maybe not as
much as Tinkerbell wanted from Peter if
you catch my drift boy did that get
creepy and I forgot about that you know
hook and you maybe you love hook maybe
you're like man you're just very
indifferent to hook but it's a story of
adult Peter Pan going back to Never
Never Land he's got to rescue his kids
from Captain Hook played by Dustin
Hoffman and now before we get into our
movie talk about it we're gonna go to
our favorite segment two minutes with
Tim that's where Tim Reiner expert
review curation manager is going to give
us the breakdown of what critics were
saying at the time of hooks release way
back when in 1991 the era of Crystal
Pepsi take it away Tim
two minutes with him it's a
philosophical question for the ages how
much does your enjoyment of a movie
depend on the context in which you saw
it it's obviously a question unique to
everyone but it's especially difficult
to fully grasp how a film was received
at the time of its release if you
weren't there I can't tell you how many
times people who are usually a couple
years younger than me have told me that
they can't believe that hook has such a
low score on Rotten Tomatoes and I want
to tell them I was there I was 14 years
old in 1991 so I was the exact age to be
interested in a big budget family
fantasy like hook but I was also
starting to pay attention to what movie
critics had to say and I can't tell you
what a whopping disappointment Hook was
at the time there was a movie that
seemingly had everything going for it it
was a riff on a familiar story it
started Robin Williams and Dustin
Hoffman each in the midst of their
commercial and critical hot streaks
Julia Roberts at the height of her
powers Bob Hoskins Who the kids loved
and Who Framed Roger Rabbit and a
Supporting Cast that included the great
Maggie Smith Phil Collins who was still
selling millions of albums and a
soon-to-be famous Gwyneth Paltrow and of
course it was directed by Steven
Spielberg two years after Indiana Jones
in the Last Crusade which at that moment
was my favorite movie of all time and
I'm telling you the general Vibe was
that hook was a mismatch of tones and
overstuffed step pieces that just didn't
cohere as a whole that's the movie I saw
and that's the movie a lot of critics
saw and although hook did reasonably
well at the box office it was considered
a disappointment especially next to
Beauty and the Beast which was released
a couple weeks earlier and for a few
years after that hook was Anonymous with
big budget flops Spielberg himself has
said he doesn't like it all that much
but for kids a few years younger than me
hook is a formative movie it was one of
those films they watched over and over
again on VHS and for them hook wasn't a
misfire it was a magical experience it
was exciting and poignant it made them
laugh and cry it became a perennial
classic so those kids were certainly not
following the hubbub around Hook's
release Hook is rotten to 29 on the
Tomato Meter with 65 reviews and it has
a 76 audience score so what did those
critics have to say in a rotten review
Vincent Canby of the New York Times
wrote Hook is overwhelmed by a
screenplay heavy with complicated
Exposition by what are in effect big
busy non-singing non-dancing production
numbers and some contemporary can't
about rearing children and the high
price paid for Success however in a
fresh review Jay Boyer of the Orlando
Sentinel wrote it's a lot of fun to
watch over two hours of Thrills spills
elaborate sets and special effects all
tied together by pleasingly varied and
lighter than usual music score by John
Williams the Rotten Tomatoes critics
consensus raids the look of hook is
Lively indeed but Spielberg directs on
autopilot here giving in too quickly to
his sentimental syrupy qualities so
that's hook let's kick it back to
Jacqueline and Mark two people who
refuse to grow up that is very true Tim
thank you for that and I just received
some updates so we have going live as of
the night of the 24th I think midnight
the night of the 24th is our final
championship round for this Spielberg
bracket that we're doing the super
Showdown so that's going to go live so
if you all want to vote and make your
voices heard hook did not fare well Hook
was eliminated in round one but it was
paired against a monster I mean it was
paired against the the Duke the Kansas
the Kentucky of this tournament which
was E.T so E.T beat hook handily agree
disagree yes agree that yeah okay
ETV cooking it so this is literally in
round one yeah round one oh okay that's
a tough time well yeah I mean you know
hooks coming in is the 16th E.T hook won
its tiny little conference in the middle
of nowhere and it got invited to the
dance and the Clock Struck midnight for
Cinderella because it turned back into a
pumpkin so there we go E.T Indiana Jones
Jurassic Park and I think Saving Private
Ryanair is for okay I think
1975 started a shark that I think should
be in there we'll talk about it what are
we missing Josh what do you mean what
shark movie damn it 1941. that's the
shark movie sorry which does feature the
Jaws score I guess it's probably Jaws
E.T Jurassic Park in Indy I'm sorry the
man has too many iconic movies for me to
pick the final four guys made a lot of
great movies in his day and we're gonna
talk about one that we're not sure is
great with movie talk right now
foreign
you really have to start this
conversation with Steven Spielberg
though right I mean the the Maestro may
be the greatest director of all time I
think in a lot of folks's eyes because
he can do it all he can do tiny little
independent feeling movies he can do
hard-hitting dramas he can do suspense
he can do Thrillers he can also do these
big budget family that you just certify
as a classic before we even see the
movie because of the guy making it and
that's what we thought we were getting
into with hook so Brett let me ask you
first when did Steven Spielberg first
get on your radar do you have a a Steven
Spielberg moment as a kid where you're
in a theater and you're like this this
guy just made the movie of My Life
um probably E.T I mean I saw it in the
theater and that was the that was when I
paid attention to like directors I think
is what because I yeah I really really
loved that film and uh by the way took
forever to come out on VHS
the kids these days they get that stuff
right away nope that one took forever
and uh I was when it did come out on VHS
I burned that one up we had never seen
E.T because we had just missed it and I
it was tough to find it even on TV so
you just heard about this classic movie
ET and I remember my dad came home
probably got a page from somebody he was
buying a VHS in the back alley somewhere
and he came home with a copy of E.T but
this is like 1989 and really we finally
get to see this movie and so for me my
first Spielberg movie Jaclyn was Pro I
mean I saw Jaws a lot because Jaws was
just sort of always in the TV rotation
even way back when and my my grandma New
Jersey had a little pool my uncle being
what great uncles do was the pool shark
so he had a LaserDisc player so he had
movies on LaserDisc and so he'd show his
Jaws on LaserDisc which we didn't really
notice the quality so much as you had to
flip the disc every 20 minutes and then
Joss was like five discs long so it was
a process well what was Indy's it wasn't
it was it's Raiders Raiders of the Lost
Ark was 81 and then Temple of Doom was
84. and then Last Crusade was 89 but by
then I'd already been inundated with
Indiana Jones somewhat I think Raiders
is the Lost Ark was my first one on TV
okay that was my first one because I did
go to Jurassic Park wanting to go see a
Steven Spielberg movie and so I knew
like because that's what 92. what is
Jurassic Park Jurassic Park is 93 93 so
yeah I was yeah ten nine right in that
area and so I mean we kind of got
revenge Spielberg in 93 because he's
making Schindler's List a very personal
movie to him but then the Revenge comes
in with Jurassic Park because even like
as Tim intimated Steven Spielberg not
necessarily thrilled with the making of
hook I think that Steven Spielberg has
said in interviews that he maybe felt
like he was overcompensating for not
feeling like he was telling the story
right particularly in the never
Neverland sequences and so he just kind
of overcompensated by stuffing more and
more production design and and bells and
whistles into that and to be honest with
you as we get into the movie talk on
hook here my big takeaway from
re-watching it last night is is I don't
like the never Neverland stuff really I
am the weirdo and I remember even
feeling this way when I first saw it as
a kid it took forever for me to see hook
I was so excited to see it didn't get a
chance to see in the theater and then it
took another six months after it was
released on home video because we never
had the Blockbuster Video the town was
too small so we go to video update and
they had three copies of hook and they
were always Reddit out and you never got
lucky so it's like okay let's go for a
hook and Hook's not there so we would
just believe with Adventures in
Babysitting again
story of Robin Williams as an adult and
losing who he really was losing that
childlike quality then we get to never
Neverland Brett and I just feel like
it's just so overstuffed yet still empty
am I am I wrong here
that that food fight was so delightful
no it wasn't I did not enjoy the food I
had so much fun with that yeah again
last night I had fun with that okay
those kids are adorable and the one when
the when the little one like is rubbing
his face and like doing it and he goes
oh there you are that was a little
magical like oh
that's what the kids are fine it's just
like the Big Adventures in the set
pieces and they're like we're about to
break in a song but not really see this
is this is where I will agree with you
so it's a fake Musical that is what I
will give you this is the problem with
hook and this is the actual problem with
hook is that it is miscast and it is
Miss toned miscast yes this is where I
get controversial oh boy
Robin Williams we all love him obviously
plays a childlike presence within an
adult body very well there's a reason
why Jack plays very well yeah so on and
so forth but Peter is a young hero he is
a young Hercules he is a young you know
what I'm saying like like when you
really think about what Peter was
probably like think of a young Ryan
Gosling think of a young um what was his
name like that like this young hero that
you know is going to grow into something
that can fight and nothing about Robin
Williams I think sort of showed that
says Warrior you know what I'm saying I
think uh you know like honestly like
like Ben Barnes and like the way that
character sort of is portrayed honestly
the guy that's playing Louie right now
in Interview with a Vampire somebody
that's gonna grow into a very fearsome
presence that's what we want to see but
have a very childlike quality because
he's Peter Pan that's why he's a boy
that never wants to grow up because if
he grows up he's going to be towering
that's why I don't like it I think Robin
Williams as much as I hate to say it is
kind of miscast you need more of an
every man you know who I was thinking
might have been miscast because I hadn't
seen this movie in so long but it was
actually I think steals the movie is
Dustin Hoffman as Captain Hook he's
wonderful in this and that's the reason
why that works better think of Dustin
Hoffman and how he looks and I think of
it if it was this just young smarmy you
know what I mean like kid like think Tom
Sawyer I think yeah Menace think like
that but it's like this person's still
gonna grow up to pretty formidable adult
that's what the part of hookah didn't
get so does Hook lose you ever as far as
like the the adult stuff at the
beginning or are you engaged in the
story that's when I felt the Spielberg
Magic Touch I was watching this just
desperately wanting nothing to be wrong
with it
and and I did see things I was going I'm
like oh that's a little campy that's a
little oh no no like I said my son was
checking out at moments he actually left
the room when I went to go to the
bathroom how old are you son 15. wow oh
yeah you try to get the kids into this
and they just your son tried to hang in
the daughter immediately was just like I
don't like the Peter Pan story
but all right and she's 12. she's
probably would have maybe enjoyed it a
bit more but yeah it she's Discerning
she's like I don't need this in my life
yeah right I don't need this
complicating I just watching Nola homes
not wrong young Henry Cavill would have
been a great young Peter Pan and I see
what you're saying like yeah you didn't
think Peter was going to turn this
bearer of a man that they had to shave
apparently his whole body for the Peter
Pan Robin Williams a famously hairy
sweaty man I mean that's why we all look
up to him yeah again I I that's the only
thing about it he plays the childlike
aspect but that's almost what the
Betrayal is you actually want to see
this person look very like there's
nothing about you that looks childlike
and then become childlike that's the
actual that's why when you read the
Stephen wanted Tom Hanks you're like
this makes sense yeah yeah so Steve
originally wanted Tom Hanks to play this
role and I mean for me I I think the
scene that I still remember like really
getting me invested into this movie is
when uh Peter and and uh and his wife
they go to this this function and he
gives a speech and then they return home
to find that the kids are gone and
there's a freaking sword with like this
weird parchment saying that Captain Hook
is taking your kids and it's like oh
this is really cool then we start to get
the The Whimsy and I give a lot of
credit to the Maestro John Williams
Because this is nowhere near my favorite
Spielberg movie The John Williams score
in this really puts this movie on its
back at certain times and carries it
through so that's the scene for me that
really got me invested and then the rest
of the movie it just felt overstuffed
yet I was still hungry afterwards going
to Never Never Land what's the scene for
Brett Sheridan in hook that you say
that's why this movie should be fresh
that's why this movie should be
considered one of Spielberg's better
films how well the the scene of course
for me and I I I wasn't a father at the
time you know I think I was a junior in
high school when it came out and yes
it's two years older two years
um I really connected to that whole like
that his son was his his happy place you
know like that was his happy thought
that helped him fly because I at a young
age wanted to be a father I like I've
always wanted to have kids and at that I
was like oh man that would that's so
nice because that's what I
felt that having kids would feel like
and now watching with my son and going
I'm like see it's happy places his
father I'm like he's a little uh could
you fly right now if you think about
your son oh yeah I could I think because
I think about him as a little baby okay
not the knuckleheads
apparently what's the scene for uh for
Jaclyn that still gets you to say
because again I I even feel like you're
being a little spicy in this episode
because you're getting this movie to
fresh as well
spicy to get this movie to Fresh because
there's so many great things first of
all um Maggie Smith when she sees that
moment and doubles over in that bit of
action I'm like yes yes Dame two-time
Oscar Dame Maggie Smith do your thing it
walks you when she says Peter yeah
you've become a pirate I'm like oh my
God this is this is the worst case
scenario yeah yeah
um her whole moment I love Tinkerbell
giving it to Peter for all of her
unrequited love and more importantly
just for like I'm the reason why like I
literally am putting the dust around
everything that you do and you'll just
use and abuse me Justice for Tinkerbell
first
um wait wait let me finish and my
favorite last scene is at the end when
uh Tonks gets his marbles yeah that is
just give me the sunshine give me the
raid and again there's aspects of the
production design that are over the top
absolutely
um but the biggest sin is the fact that
it's a musical that wants to be a
musical I meant to say that Miss Cass
and a musical that wants to be a musical
it just it's every time you feel like
it's about to lean into something like
that then it just sort of pivots in a
slightly different direction yes the
Tinkerbell stuff to me is weird because
I I don't know what Tinkerbell is is
hoping for in this movie I think that
she's completely overshooting her bounds
with hitting on Peter the guy's married
okay picture of her world for all of her
existence and I don't blame her it's
some weird like she's this big it
doesn't matter how is this gonna be
how's this relationship gonna function
is built on him you cannot like she's
just gonna delude herself because again
he's not giving her any agency to love
anything else now look I will say
because Julia Roberts plays Tinkerbell
this is Julia Roberts in 1991. Julia
Roberts goes from being a mosquito to
being full like size Julia Roberts maybe
my wife and I have a conversation
look honey I love you but you know we
she's got Wings you know so let's also
talk about the fact that like again the
one thing I will say when they do the
flashback scene and we get Gwyneth for
that like one minute also one of Fosters
in this right Gwyneth Paltrow is in this
which I'm gonna go ahead and say is
absolutely a nepotism role because she
was not
nothing about what a culture is acting
at that point is because you're a live
dancer's kid that got you that little
part in a Steven Spielberg movie which
you can make a direct line between that
and Shakespeare and love and bye bye
Oscar like legitimately legitimately so
sorry all I want to say about about this
is
she's just okay to sexual assaulting the
granddaughter in bed I want to give her
a real kiss and she's like oh okay so
long as it's not a thimble you can make
out with her while she can't consent but
go ahead that was the part that I was
like
nobody's about to do
pull him away my granddaughter they
introduce them formally maybe not that
also that it's weird that is the one
thing that is weird that whole scene is
weird Okay the whole you know Grandma is
his love interest back in the day then
the daughter becomes like that whole
circle is is weird anyway it was very
confusing to follow it's Peter 100
absolutely had sex they absolutely had
sex and then his granddaughter did too
yeah okay I know but I know Tinkerbell
is is like a Sex Fiend in Never Never
Land but it doesn't really seem to be a
prevalent desire for most of the for
most of the folks there not even the
Pirates they just seem content to like
sing songs and drinks that's why they're
boys I guess they assume that they're
not they're not at that point yet I
guess so but I mean Dustin Hoffman just
seems happy you know Captain Hook just
seems happy in a little chamber he's got
I love all the different hooks that he
has I love his drinking hook I just
figured him and schmee were okay that's
Fair yeah relationship has layers Bob
Hoskins is fun to speak yeah he really
is punished me also uh the Glenn Close
if you want to be like today anyone
listening to this you can be a hero on
Tick Tock by doing that like I've seen
like three tick tocks of people being
like did you know I'm like this stuff
like went up on YouTube like five years
ago this is not this is new information
on Tick Tock this is not new information
on YouTube well we're probably already
getting a lot of fans saying why aren't
you talking about this character and
we're gonna stop that right now with
Rufio played by Dante Biscoe who's just
become this pop culture sensation of a
character and I understand why because
Rufio sort of took over he's the pan the
current pan in Neverland and because
Peter's gone away and became an adult
and is now making deals on his cell
phone so Rufio steps in by all accounts
the warrior kind of person you're
talking about which is what you'd want
for Peter how does Rufio the character
and his Arc strike Brett Sheridan well
this one hits close to home because roof
feel I met at the Saddle Ranch the actor
really yes
um just kind of Never Never Land for
it's it's right on Sunset next to The
Comedy Store yeah Never Never Land for
people who like bandanas met uh uh
several celebrities there back in the
time and it was there was free parking
so these must have been uh fellow cheap
uh comedians that's what we would tell
when I was working the the parking lot
at the comedy street that people pull in
thinking like customers thinking they
could park there oh no and I was like no
but honestly if you park at Saddle Ranch
and you just walk in grab a free biscuit
come on down yep oh piece of cake so you
met Rufio and you told him what about
hook
um well I just said I loved him and hook
you know okay no I'm sure he's never
gotten that he was he was finding out
where the after party was and I had the
I had a friend that ran this like
underground you know say a secret word
behind a building that was a cool thing
for me of loving him in this film yeah
and then returning that yeah returning
that love but his his didn't like him in
the beginning you know I I didn't the
Rufio I would he angered me as the
character see I watched this movie last
night I understood everything that Rufio
was feeling because this guy just shows
up meanwhile I've cultivated a nice
little career for myself as the leader
of this tribe maybe things aren't going
the best and never never win but come on
I mean you know it's it's not gonna be
sunshine and Roses right away he's got
the sword he carries it like a warrior
he fights Captain Hook at the end and it
still guts me to this day even though I
don't really care about this movie that
much I hate that they killed rufia this
is the weirdest thing about this movie
this is another thing when I say of like
the Kindergarten Cop of it it's like
what kids get murdered it's the hard
ball Keanu Reeves and Hardball that's
like the end of this I mean that is a
lot that is let's play worse hardball's
a little more intense I'll give you that
to think about what that meant and those
implications I'm like Mark wow it's
getting dark in these last days before
the special Hardball gets a little gets
a little sadder I will say because you
feel like Rufio maybe can patch things
up at some point maybe in the real world
but it's a bummer to see Captain Hook
get him like that it is about to see it
and it's hard that's the part of this
movie like it makes so many turns it
gives us this beautiful moment with this
kid where you you get to see him sort of
saying you know I'm doing whatever he's
like you know the coolest guy on the
Block and then you kill him yeah I it
have no point to me I don't know why you
would I mean that was back when you just
murked any character for motivation like
they were still often dogs in big
releases back in the early 90s so you
know the dogs now you're never going to
see a dog die in a movie unless unless
it's the first John Wick or Marley and
Me since 2000 somewhere like it's so
it's it's it's meant to be the most
disgusting thing you can do to something
yeah right right you cannot like pass
over it the way this movie passes over
sort of like Rufus yeah and and we miss
him and it is a fun scene when we are
sort of realizing that Robin Williams
can actually become Peter Pan the moment
you're talking about where the kid is
kind of molding his face into smiles and
they drew a line in the sand and all the
other kids aren't sure which line to be
on like like I found that kind of like
endearing and Charming to and um it just
uh it just still bums me up but I feel
like the movie wraps up you know okay
and Robin Williams that you're never
going to be able to accuse the guy of a
lack of effort when it comes to to
pulling off a roll even in one that
Jaclyn feels he's somewhat miscasted do
you subscribe to that at all or do you
feel like Robin Williams was the right
choice at this time in his career even
prior to hearing what you said but I I
totally agree with you because if he
grew up and was you know fully invested
in becoming a businessman he'd probably
hit the gym too you know and in him that
pan transition from the childish nature
he took that to become driven in
business so yeah maybe he's hitting the
gym as well I wouldn't even say it's
hitting the gym I don't mind the fact
that he's like pudgy at the beginning
getting of it I just think the young boy
that is cheeky and and irreverent being
hidden behind this very average sort of
looking you know what I mean figure yeah
I think is the is the greater trick it's
the greater transition he still looks
pretty much like he you know what I'm
saying he still looks like he does
before it doesn't really like you don't
feel like it changes over imagine Leo in
like once upon a time in Hollywood
like that version of Leo think about it
that way but he's like but he's or sorry
the version of Leo that's in don't look
up that sort of like pudgy not as cool
looking guy but you turn him into Leo in
you know whatever you know the Reverend
like looking all Grizzly or whatever
like making that turn you know because I
thought you were kind of giving it to
put you guys no no no in fact he needs
to be pudgy it's about the transition I
think it's about the transition and then
you see this guy's very thin and then
you see him in the like what he used to
be you don't really see that in this
when he's Peter Pan you definitely see
that he's better and you definitely see
that he's Lively but you don't
necessarily see what he used to be you
just see this guy has embraced his youth
except for one scene except for one
scene where I couldn't tell because this
scene where we were joking earlier like
they had to shave Robin Williams's
entire body multiple times like five
minutes before they went there I'm sure
and he he's got some ABS yeah he's got
some abs and so I couldn't tell if they
were artificially pudging him up like
underneath his shirt adding like a
little pillow I think so I feel like you
could tell in the plane okay yeah it was
the roles were all in the wrong because
he oh he's he was such a barrel like a
built kind of guy anyway and again not
saying that he's bad it's it's just um
there's a visual representation of that
character that you want to see you want
to see that it's more hidden in the
beginning which is also not hidden you
can tell that it's like this used to be
the funniest guy in every room he walked
in that's not what you want to see when
you see him you want to see not that and
then he becomes that that's an
interesting point you make because in
this one even more so than like the
serious Robin Williams role you know
there's like the joke about bearded
Robin Williams is like in a serious
drama Awakenings Good Will Hunting this
is the one where I did even feel him
being like I'm not sure what the tone is
here because I am the quickest wit in
within a thousand miles of this set yes
and sometimes he delivers lines like he
knows that and then other times it's
like I have to consciously hold back
because I'm not necessarily playing a
character like that so it was just an
interesting and he's he's fine in the
roll no but it just you feel the
comedian in him struggling to be like
when do I get to come out and play and
that's the thing and that's what I am
not buying in some of the best visual
parts of the movie okay well Brett did
uh Brett did bring in a DVD of hook for
us that he I mean seriously so this was
at your house this was in I've got a
drawer of DVDs that I should have gotten
rid of a long time ago but uh don't do
that yeah physical media will never die
super bit yeah so you but you but you're
gonna open that right to to watch it but
uh I I ended up just branding I thought
it would be funnier to bring in the the
wrapped copy and uh I told my wife and
she's like
it's still it's even funnier because
this is just just purchase for love
there's no other reason that is hook in
all its many forms and it did have a two
really cool posters you have like the
character poster yeah it was sort of
like that classic adventure
swashbuckling poster and then you just
had the classic hook which was like oh
this is gonna be good so hook does have
some redeeming qualities I still can't
get it to fresh after this conversation
seems like Jacqueline is at least making
it fresh at Jason barely into the realm
of fresh fresh for love you know what
it's the writer in me knows that this
was written by Design and written by a
studio and so like I can't really love
it but as you said Carrie Fisher was
called to punch up some of the dialogue
so it's like it's like if this is what
is happening this is not ideal
situations Hook is a perfect example of
get the script before you start shooting
I know that's not always the case but
get the script done get it pretty and
Brett you still feel that hook is a
fresh movie I I I wanted to I really did
like I when when I was when Brian asked
me like he said I go have you seen hook
I'm like I love hook our producer Brian
yeah up and then I'm like watching I'm
going oh I'm gonna have to defend this
Rose Colored Glasses yeah it kind of it
was tough but again I was watching it at
a different time in my life and I think
that we we didn't think about things the
way we did like with this the whole
critiquing of films among young people
was not a thing when I was 17. yeah it
could have been but no it was the Siskel
and eberts and stuff like that that were
like that's boring we just went to and
we were more forgiving I grew up on 80s
films I mean come on I'm very forgiving
to films
like come on yeah my favorite movies was
breaking I mean come on I mean I know
how you feel about breaking the first
one but oh wow see I definitely love
Electric Boogaloo way more because I
feel that one just was what it was
whereas in break-in was still trying to
be a movie with like a narrative
structure wow a conversation wrote I did
not think we were gonna go down did not
think we were taking that breaking exit
today oh Hey listen also another one
that features heavily within the book uh
this is the last thing I was will say at
least for for hook as far as like
long-term repeal or whatever for all the
folks listening to this right now who
have waited so patiently for us to do
hook I apologize because they're so bad
that we did not love it as much because
they have been in the comments so let us
know how you feel we may have to do this
one again because yeah I do
wonderful it's like wondrous like it
does provide Wonder there's moments of
Wonder no it is a wonderful in that
sense in the sense that you can get lost
in its wonder and it is magical in that
and there's still there's a movie that
just screened in Los Angeles that
everyone their mother is waiting on and
it does not bring magic or wonderment
and so I have to give this one a little
bit of an edge because that was what its
goal was and it achieved it all right
well let's get into another movie then
that I think a lot of people are
counting on bringing them wonderment and
big budget returns and and all those
things that you want with the Steven
Spielberg movie and that would be his
new film which is out as of today in
theaters in the United States the Fable
men's I have not yet seen it Jacqueline
and Brett Sheridan have so let it fly
Brad first is the fablemans one of
Steven Spielberg's better movies yes
absolutely yes
um didn't know anything about it going
into it
um just knew that I got to go to a
screening yeah it was a free movie yeah
I gotta go to a free movie
um and uh yeah I I didn't I didn't know
what to think about it started out I was
kind of like oh this is kind of cute I
mean the beginning is like oh this is
cute it's just a family I didn't exceed
much you know of it to where it got to
um the heart-wrenching you know and and
then you see the wanderment of you know
like the the be Loosely based you know
Steven Spielberg character and how he
you know he got his passion for
filmmaking and it's basically acts like
a love letter to his parents is what I
read but Jaclyn I'm kind of like Brett
in here where I know very little about
the fablemens we shortchanged the
audience with our synopsis for hooks yes
can you briefly without spoiling I guess
too much uh so the fablemans basically
is a semi autobiographical tale of
Steven Spielberg's his Youth and falling
in love in cinema with Cinema from being
a very young boy going to see some old
Hollywood favorites with his parents and
that first experience of being sort of
dazzled by The Wonder of Cinema to
becoming an adolescent and maybe not
loving it as much much because people
around him were telling him that he
needs to give up his little compassion
until the very end when he lets his
passion and he and he I guess sort of
Champions himself to be an artist okay
um to his parents and this is all
playing Out Among one of the more
formative aspects of his childhood which
was his parents divorce and he sort of
and sort of like him becoming a
filmmaker dealing with the trauma of his
parents divorce and sort of coming
through all of those is where the Fable
mistakes it's incredible Steven
Spielberg I I absolutely think uh it is
one of the best movies he's ever made
and I think uh you can make a very uh
clear line from Moonlight which was
somewhat Barry Jenkins and uh definitely
Tyrell McCrary story to Roma where that
was Alfonso Quran right taking some
imagination to all of these movies that
we've had this year Empire of light
Bardo a couple years ago with Belfast
babelman's I think of all of the movies
put together is the one that Embraces
the cinema along with the Memoir it it
to me and again not even knowing really
what the movie was about other than it
was about this kid who wants to be a
filmmaker and Steven Spielberg and
obviously his history so it felt to me
sort of like the way Martin Scorsese
made Hugo where it's just like a nod to
every movie to the beginning of talking
pictures and how much they've inspired
him wrapped inside this fun story kind
of like Steven Spielberg going down his
own history but also the history of
becoming a filmmaker in the era that he
came up where unlike a lot of his peers
who were getting into USC film school he
applied twice and and didn't get in so
he had to go he had to go to one of the
CAL States I think yeah he wins one of
the CAL States and he was part of the
whole movie brats era that was you know
it was it was the guys that Corman saw
that he saw Spielberg he saw Coppola he
saw uh Kubrick to a certain extent these
guys that weren't outside of the
Hollywood System that you know the
Wilders and John Fords and all of those
guys were they were making these big
movies they were doing you know that
sort of thing these guys are coming out
in love with French new wave and Corman
like gave them all their shots shot and
they eventually became Studio players
but yeah they had to they were
marginalized themselves just because
they didn't want to do the Grand MGM
type pictures that they were making uh
the fablements Brett is this a is this a
movie that you take the family to see
you recommend it to the families
listening and watching right now
probably at an airport I would say
um older children I don't think that
like uh even even my 12 year old I don't
know it might it's a little heavy you
know in that sense okay because with the
divorce and and the way the divorce
unfolds is very you know interesting and
not something I don't know if both of
y'all's eyes got big when he talked
about the divorce there's the bomb's
gonna be dropped on me informative and
Michelle Williams stars in it Seth
Brogan stars in it both of them have
incredible performances I mean Michelle
Williams plays Steven Spielberg's uh
mother and Michelle said that she was
personally like I read an interview with
her because I saw it at Tiff and and
then when she was doing interviews at
the time she definitely talked about how
you know he saw her in costume and just
cried because he couldn't deal with it
wow his mother's obviously passed and
you know his father's past and so you
know getting Paul and Michelle to play
his piece Paul Dano yeah is like a huge
honor in general you know the same thing
that I think uh Kenneth Branagh did with
with
um with Belfast yeah Belfast and Jamie
and Claire but I will just put it to you
this way in the in the grand scheme of
things it's remarkable I really do hope
people will see it but I love the fact
that Steven Spielberg is still like
giddy as a teenager about this movie
like he literally is like I saw him the
night of the premiere and he was like oh
people like it like the guy is like
legitly like he's he's just like that
he's just like that he's just a chill
dude who wants people to like his movies
even though he
know he's so many of them but he's still
just like a filmmaker being like I hope
people like it and that that final
bracket I guess is is going to be up as
of midnight and what is The Showdown
what is the ultimate Steven Spielberg
movie as we close shop up here we don't
have a mailbag this week so I'll just
simply put it to everybody maybe this
conversation changed your mind about
some of the movies the best Steven
Spielberg movie of all time is sorry
y'all gonna be mad at me on this one the
color purple because of all the movies
that Steven Spielberg did that was the
one where he had to learn the most and
that was the one we had to do the most
and that was the one where he did in
fact on top of that 11 Oscar nominations
on a movie where you were literally
trying to give black folks a sense of
agency and representation that they've
never seen before with that cast think
about how dark-skinned that cast was
think about that cast think about the
way they look that movie can only get
made by Steven Spielberg and he had to
Humble the heck out of himself
to make it all right Brad follow that I
have to see I've seen The Color Purple a
lot and that was on my it wasn't top of
my list as well Whoopi Goldberg uh
partly auditioned early said her
presence I guess auditioned at The
Comedy Store and Steven Spielberg came
to the belly room to see her there and
then it's like you know yeah that one
was on heavy rotation on one of the
movie channels yeah sure yeah yeah
um Empire the sun which I had a
conversation with you uh I made a
reference to that and you found out
you'd never seen that and I still
haven't seen that part of the sun yeah
oh that one is one that I would put up
there but I just say I'll have to go
back to Best in terms of just you know
me the moment seeing it my age E.T for
me has always been just like that that
one was so magical and I was I was kind
of with Drew Barrymore I really felt
like this was a real creature I think at
the time I was like oh my God it's my
kind of alien drinks beer it's Reese's
Pieces I couldn't I can jive with that
but you know for me E.T I used to like
kind of joke that I just didn't trust ET
because I thought it was a spy not a
botanist I was kind of rooting for the
government I watched it I don't know
like six months ago or something and I
it actually hurt me the other way
because I was so compassionate and
empathetic for E.T it like actually took
away my enjoyment of the movies I felt
so bad for this poor bastard who gets
marooned on this planet the government
wants to carve him open the scene where
they have him captured and he's like in
the government like tent hospital and
they're about to like dissect him I'm
like losing my pale oh my God what are
we doing today it was too much Steve too
much so I go Jaws you go with Josh give
me jaws man okay give me three guys on a
boat looking for a shark okay I'm gonna
tell you two E.T fans something that is
from a comedy special that I have
memorized which I think is hilarious
because I did not love this but it is
from Greg Davies and he talks about E.T
and he says I can ruin that for anybody
who says it loves it in one sentence
which is this if you walked out to your
garage and you saw that thing out there
[Laughter]
boom that's it you would not care that
it was magical
you would kill it because no human being
seeing that in their garage is not gonna
think of it as a threat and so I would
feel bad afterwards is what I'm saying I
would crush it with a shovel and I feel
really bad afterwards we hope you feel
better after this hour of movie chat
discussion based around hook and a
little the Fable men's and Spielberg's
entire uvra if you will
yeah I can't get that I can't get all
the specifics of the French language
down but uh Brett Sheridan it was an
honor having you for the first time it's
taken us well over 100 episodes which is
too long to get a Brett Sheridan here
but we did it we'd love to have you back
again where can all the people find you
and your movie reviews that I hear uh
you get some level of therapy out of yes
well that's a new segment we have on the
uh Christian harloff Channel part of the
big thing uh it's something I came up
with where I review uh films laying on a
therapist's uh couch uh while Christian
uh asked me the questions which Mark
knows is helpful for me because my
reviewing skills talking by myself for a
long period of time tend to go off into
these magical places if not necessarily
about the film or how I got it at
Netflix or I couldn't find it at a
certain red box so right now I'm doing
an example your reviews tend to go from
The Real World to Never Never Land very
Never Never Land so this is one to dial
me in a little bit and uh get me to a
place and I feel great about it I love
the concept I think people are starting
to like and it's like oh it's just a new
take on doing uh film reviews so that's
cute check it out and hopefully it blows
up and I become super huge and uh is
that Mr Wigley where he's already has a
monstrous social media presence thank
you so much Fred it was great uh y'all
can uh shoot us an email anytime RT is
wrong at rottentomatoes.com let us know
what movies we should be talking about
and thank you as Jacqueline intimated
earlier thank you for all of your
wonderful hook reviews your hook videos
your hook takes we appreciate it we hope
you are able to identify with at least
one of the opinions presented probably
not the guy talking to you right now
um Jacqueline it is a big week for us
here but we don't know what our topic is
going to be next week it's it's a
mystery yeah we're we're playing fast
and loose with the facts over here I
mean we are literally just taking it day
by day we're going where the Vibes take
us as I like to say going where the
Vibes take us so I have no idea what
we're doing but we'll be here and y'all
will be listening and we're gonna have a
good time with it Happy Thanksgiving
everyone Happy Thanksgiving can I tell
you something personally what I love
that bad company shirt I love that it's
Bad Company Shooting Star from 75. that
band has so many classic Tunes shooting
star may be my favorite one of all of
them moving on a great song for a
comedian so uh that's that's at that
Jack when I Mark Ellis live once again
my comedy special tapes December 3rd 7
to 9 30 p.m shows right here in Los
Angeles you can get tickets at
markellis.live for Brett Sheridan
Jacqueline Coy our Incredible Crew here
in studio at Rotten Tomatoes is wrong
thanks for watching and uh I guess think
happy thoughts and maybe you'll fly one
day
[Music]
thank you